الى كوسوفو وهناك اندلعت مواجهات بين
الشرطه ومواطنين من اصول صربيا احرقت فيها
سيارات للشرطه في البلديات الشامل
الشماليه على الحدود مع صربيا وقالت
الشرطه الكوسوفيه في بيار لانها تتخذ
اجراءات وتدابير لمنع جميع الانشطه
الاجراميه وتقدم المساعده لبلديات فيتشان
وليبوستابيك الشماليه
ومن ناحيه الثانيه اعلن الرئيس الصربيه
وضع جيش بلده في حاله تاهب قتالي قصوى
وامر وحداته بالاقتراب من الحدود مع
كوسوفو وقال وزير الدفاع
الصربيتش انه اصدر اوامر بتحرك قواته
عاجلا الى حدود اقليم كوسوفو واضاف ان من
الواضح ان الارهاب يستهدف الطائفه الصربيه
في كوسوفو حسب تعبيره
ومن جهه ثانيه حمل كبير الموظفين في رئاسه
كوسوفو بالريم فيلا صربيا حملها مسؤوليه
التصعيد في المناطق الشماليه بكوسوفو وقال
كبير موظف الرئاسه في كتبه في تغريده ان
اي محاوله تسلل لعسكريين الصرب في زي
المدني الى شمال كوسوفو سيعرض السلامه
والاستقرار في المنطقه للخطر واتهم النظام
الصربيه بتصعيد الوضع لضمان بقائه
معنى من سرايف ومراسل الجزيره احمد بجيتش
احمد اذا توتر جديد في شمال كوسوفو على
الحدود مع صربيا ما الملابسات كيف بدا هذا
التوتر الجديد
ارى انما منذ عده ساعات هناك توتر
يقول البلديات فقط في شمال الكوسوفه
وعندما بدات قوات شرطه وصفيه
بدخوله الى المباني او بلديات في شمال
الكسوف بعد تحقيق او
لتنفيذ الانتخابات او نتاجر الانتخابات
التي اجريت في نهايه الشهر الماضي
جاءت انتخابات في شمال القصور
بعد بعد انسحاب جميع
اغلبيه سلبيه من تلك البلديات ومقاطعه
عملها فيها
وتم اعلانها ان انتخابات في تلك المنطقه
وتفوت ما يقل عن 4% من سكان البحرين
البان ويتم اختيار اربعه رئيس رؤساء تلك
البلديات من قوميه الالبانيه واليوم شرطه
الخصوصيه حاولت بدخاله
بالفعل قبل الثواني راي الشرطه الكوسوفيه
دخلت الى تلك المباني
وبدات بعملها هناك السلطات الجديده في
شمال الكوسوفه هذه اجراءات او هذه
التطورات التي شهدتها اليوم اليس اولى من
نوعها هناك بنحيين واخر ترجل
تقيم كلا باراسي
الحواجز الاطارات الطرق وبقيه الامور التي
تؤدي الى
الاستقرار طبعا من جانب سلطات الخصوصيه
تقول انها لن تسمح
باقامه النظام الموازي في شمال البلاد
وهناك ايضا اتهامات المتبادله بين الاطراف
بين صربيا وكوسوفا حول التوترات الاخيره
السلطات الكوسوفيه تقول ان صربيا تقف
ورايحاته الاعمال شغب
تحرض الشعب
صربي اقليه التي تعيش في كوسوفه تحرضها ضد
السلطات الكوسفيه سمعنا قبل قليل ايضا
وراينا في شركات التواصل الاجتماعي في
تويتر
سفينه امريكي
ويطالب من سلطات الكوسوفيه بانسحاب سريه
من شمال
ويطالبون ايضا من الاتحاد الاوروبي لتهدئه
الامور اما بالنسبه دخول الجيش العربي
والامور التي سميناها قبل قليل ان تذكرتها
في الخطر ان الجيش الصربي هناك تاهب
القصوى لجيش الفردي وتوجه بعض
الفرق الى الى حدود المنطقه حدوديه بين
الكسوفيه طبعا الكثير من المحللين يرون ان
دخول الجيش الصربي الى منطقه الى حدود
التجاوز حدود كسوفه هذا يستبعدونه
لان
حلف شمال الاطلسي يتواجدون هناك بالكثافه
واكبر قاعده عسكريه الامريكيه في جنو ب
الشرقي اوروبا يتواجد في كوسوفا وكثير من
المحللين يرون ويستبعدون تماما دخول
القوات الرسميه الصربيه الى تلك المنطقه